مشاهدينا ننتقل الى السيد يوسف عزت مستشار
السياسي لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد
قوات الدعم السريع اهلا بك السيد يوسف
معنا في هذه التغطيه بدايه اذا لو تابعت
معنا قبل قليل الفريق الكباشي يتحدث عن
موافقه الجيش على هدنه لاربع وعشرين ساعه
اشترط فيها ضمان ضبط الدعم السريع ما هو
موقفكم من ذلك وكيف تعلقون ايضا
نحن لغنا علمنا ذلك فيما يخص الهدنه من
البارحه اتفقنا مع السيد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي هو الذي اخترع هذه الهدنه وبعد
الدول الصديقه وافقنا واعطيناه الموافقه
كامله على ان يستجيب الطرف الاخر فللهدنه
وهي الهدنه انسانيه
نحن منا الساعه الثامنه بالامس تم توجيه
كل القوات في المواقع المختلفه قوات الدعم
السريع ان تلتزم بالهدنه وانت تحافظ على
المغارات التي تسيطر عليها ولا تتحرك اي
تحرك هجومي او عن تسهل عبور المدنيين عبر
الكباري التي نسيطر عليها هذا هذا كان
توجيه واضح من قياده الدعم السريع بالامس
واعلن ذلك اليوم في تغريده قبل خروجه
كباشيه وكلامي في نفس الوقت نحن الساعه
الثالثه صباحا نتعرض لهجوم في القياده
العامه التي نسيطر عليها هجوم مكثف من من
الجيش بالطائرات والهجوم على الارض تم
الهجوم ولكن لم نهاجم اي جهه
للعبور كل المواطنين معالقين في بين المدن
الثلاثه الداهرين المستشفيات سهلنا في
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها في بحري في ام
درمان سهلنا للمواطنين من يخرج من البيوت
اذا كان البقالات فاتحه للاسف مضغ
البقالات مغلقه ولكن هنالك مواقع هنالك
بعض المواقع تفتح ليس لدينا اي اعتراض على
الهدنه ونحن اصل التزمنا بها منذ الامر
ولكن ابلغنا الامريكاني انه انه الطرف
التالي لم يلتزم بالهدنه
وعليهم واجباري على ذلك ويبدو انهم اتصلوا
بقياده الجيش لتخرج
هذا الموقف نحن نت صرف بمسؤوليه تامه
وقدر تخضع للسيطره كامله تتحرك خطه لا
تتحرك بدون هو سؤالي السيد يوسف يعني هل
انتم على اتصال كامل مع جميع وحداتكم مع
الارض لان الروايه التي يقولها الجيش او
التي يتبناها الجيش بان القيادات في الدعم
السري فقدت التواصله مع الوحدات على الارض
هذه دعايه مفرده الوحدات الارض هو غايه
قوات الدعم السريه
وهو الذي يوجه عقيم الاتصالات الخاصه
بالدعم السريع والذي وجه كل وحدات الدعم
السريع
في محدده للقياده
ترتكز على السيطره على المجرات التي
سيطرنا عليها
وتعميلك كباري ونحن نتحرك بخطه دفاعيه
ليست هجوميه كل المجرات التي تسيطر عليها
نحافظ عليها ندافع عنها
كل الفرق عليها
ان تعبر هذه وتضربنا هذه هي
هذه الدفاعيه تامين ولايه الخرطوم حمايه
المدنيين لان هنالك هنالك
علي كردي الان تروع المدنيين تدخل البيوت
هنالك من يرتدي الدعم السريع قبضنا اكثر
من 25 شخص ينتظيم الاسلامي يرتدون سريع
ومشلحين من الجيش لترويع الامنين اصدرنا
بيان بذلك هنالك محاوله لاختراق قواتنا
بعربات عليها نمر عسكريه نمر الدعم
السريعه او لوحات الدعم السريع تم تجهيزها
من الجيش والباس عناصرها زي الدعم السريع
واقامه داخل القوات التي تخترق الخطوط
الدفاعيه للدعم السريع ايضا تعاملنا معاها
وتم القبض عليها الجيش الان حائر الكباشي
الذي يتحدث ترك مكتبه نحن الان
اعراض القياده العامه وزيه الرسمي فهو
الان لا
يقتنع وعندما كان يتحدث معنا في العربيه
قال انه متواجد داخل القياده العامه
بامكانك ان تقدم وجهه نظرك كما تريد لكن
فضلا من غير توجيه مثل هذه
التوصيفات نحن ممتنون لوجودك معنا ونعم
يمكنك ان تعبر عن ذلك باي طريقه اخرى
يعني هو ايضا يقول الكباشي ان قوات الدعم
السريع تستعد لاستقبال طائرات طائرات
مساعدات في مروي ما ردكم على ذلك ايضا هل
تترقون دعما خارجيا في هذا التوقيت
[موسيقى]
لان في 11 طائره عسكريه تتبع للجيش لم
ندمرها لانها هي من ممتلكات الشعب
السوداني ولكن نحافظ عليها
استخدام مطار مروي واغلاق الطائرات لطلب
هناك طائره مصريه احترقت في مطار مروي سيد
يوسف
وتم
طائرتين تم تدمير طائره اخرى ايضا نحن
انسحبنا ومعنا 27 من ضباط جنود الجنود
المصريين حمايتنا وما زالت حمايتنا حتى
الان ولدينا قنوات اتصال مع الجاري المصري
نحن ليس لدينا علاقه بالطائرات المصريه
لاننا نعلق سبب تواجدهم في في المطار ما
هو مصير الجنود المصريين حاليا
نحن نحاول بشكل او باخر لايجاد صيغه
لتسليمهم لقيادتهم في مصر وهم في عمان لو
هم ليسوا لحايل وليسوا اسفه
نحن كل الذي نعمله حتى لا يقول يتم
تصفيتهم من قبل القوات المسلحه
والاستخبارات العسكريه لنا نحن نحتفظ بهم
لحمايتهم اولا والحمايه موجوده في اتفاقيه
اتفاقيه شراكه امنيه مع التدريبيه ايضا مع
القوات المسلحه السودانيه لماذا لماذا
تصفيهم القوات المسلحه وهي كانت اصل
متواجده معهم في في قواعدهم
المصريين للمعركه اصلا
الرئيس المصري ونحترفهم انه ليس فرحهم في
هذه الحرب ولن يتدخل لصالح اي طرف من
الاطراف موقف مشرف ونحترمه جدا ونتعامل
معه وترد له جنوده السيد يوسف اودك مع
القدر الامكان ماذا بعده 24 ساعه
الشرفاء الذين لا ينتمون للتنظيم الاسلامي
وليس لديهم مصلحه في الحرب التي كذا
البرهان الجيش لها واتخذ قرارها بالتنسيق
مع التيار الاسلام المتجدد فهذه
القيادات داخل الجيش وهي تقود للان
قوات كبيره جدا من الجيش لديهم موقف نحن
نتفاوض معهم
ونبيدا وقت الحرب انسحاب الجيش اعاده
الدعم السريع لمغراتي تسليم
الاسرع بيننا او حمايتهم وهذه هذه
المفاوضات لسه لم تتبلور عنها فكره لكن
لازم ان تجد طريقه داخليه بينك سودانيين
لوقف هذا العنف الدعم السريع ليس لديه
عداء مع المؤسسه العسكريه ولكن لديه اعداء
او استهداف تم استهدافه بشكل مباشر من
التنظيم الاسلامي فكان هذا
الامر معروفا والقوه السياسيه تعلم ذلك
والبرهان نفسه قد اخترناه هنالك تحرك
اسلامي داخل الجيش لكنه لكننا لم نكن نعلم
هو الذي يقول هذا التحرك وهو الذي المنسر
مع القيادات الاسلاميه في الخارج خارج
المؤسسه العسكريه
داخل الجيش سيدي يوسف يعني هل هو وليد
اللحظه ام كان ذلك سي خلال الفتره الماضيه
وانتم على على وفاق وشراكه مع قوات الجيش
طيله هذه المده
العمليه السياسيه الغاليه الى حل للازمه
السياسيه في السودان وترتيم السلطه
وانسحاب المؤسسه العسكريه من الجيش كانت
القيادات الاسلاميه ترفض هذا الحل وعبرت
عن ذلك كثيرا جدا انها ترفض هذا الحل
ونجعت للجيش عبى عنها داخل الجيش ونفغت
وفي الاخر اجبرت البرهان
انه يقود انقلاب يتخلص فيه من الدعم
السريع ويتخلص من القوه السياسيه ويتخلص
من كل شيء ويحكم منفردا بدعم من الديار
الاسلامي
منظمه من الدائره الاسلامي والبرهان على
راس هذه الخطه
وبدليل انه غامها جمل بمهاجمتنا يوم 15
ابريل دون اي اسباب واضحه نحن كنا على
القوات المسلحه اللجنه من ثلاثه لواءات
لجنه فنيه لاداره الملف الملف الاصلاح
الامني والدمج وهذه العمليات لتخرج وكانت
تصل لنتائج مرضيه للطرفين نحن كنا موافقين
غادتنا انه يصلوا لحل وكنا على مشارف
عمليات سياسيه تنهي الازمه سياسيه كلها
ولكن التيار
لديه تخصيص
انا لديه شهوه في السلطه شهوه بالسلطه ولم
يكن جادا في العمليه السياسيه والان
القوات المسلحه
وهنالك
الشرفاء داخل الق
وات ويتعاملون معه
ولكن البره
يعني هو الذي المسؤول عن كل المعادله التي
يعاني منها المدنيين هم المسؤول عن كل
الموت الذي حصل هو الذي حرك الطائرات وهو
الذي دكه البيوت العامه هو الذي هو الذي
يتحمل هذه المسؤوليه نحن كطرف تمت
مهاجمتنا
هذه الحرب وهذه المعارك هي الان باتت
واقعا في المشهد السوداني حاليا ما هو
الهدف الاسمى بنسبه للدعم السريع في خوض
هذه المعارك
الدعم السريع يغاتل من اجل خيارات الشعب
السوداني ليس للدعم السريع لا طموح شخصي
ولا ولا مشروع يتحرك منه الدعم السريع
فوجي بالهجوم لانه كان متزن بعمليه سياسيه
وقع عليها وفوجب الهجوم وتصدى لها دعم
الان على الارض هنالك واقع جديد هذا
الواقع الجديد يفرض شروط جديده هذه الشروط
الجديده ليست بين الدعم السريع والجيش هذه
الشروط الجديده الجديده بين الدعم السريع
وشركاء الجيش
والغور المدنيه السياسيه لديها مصلحه في
التحول الديمقراطي لديها مصلحه في ابعاد
التنظيم الاسلامي ونحن الان هزمناه
وسنتستا كاملا من اجل مصلحه السودان ولي
السودان بتحول مدني بص انتخاب المنتخبه
السودان بمستقبل مشرق لقد اعاق التنظيم
الاسلامي تطور السودان لقد الجيش استخدم
الجيش في انقلاب 89 وحكم البلاد لمده 30
سنه بالحديد والنار مستخدما المؤسسه
العسكريه وما زال يطمح
للاستخسريه
لتحفيته ومطالبه ولانها بخيرات البلاد
وليرها المصير البلاد الشعب السوداني حسب
هذا الخيار في 19 ديسمبر بثوره مشهوده شهد
عليها كل العالم والان الشعب السوداني هو
الذي يقرر مصير بمستقبل مستقبل السودان
هذه العناصر التي تريد ان تتسلق مره اخرى
على الجيش لقد انتهت وانتهت احلامها وكشفت
مشروعها طيب شكرا جزيلا لك السيد يوسف عزه
المستشار السياسي لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده
وقائد قوات الدعم السريع شكرا جزيلا لكم